all right now to the left it's true
um thank you all right let's go to the
latest show of Tolerance congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green says she was
attacked at a restaurant last night
because of her political views uh this
comes just one week after she posted a
tweet about America's quote National
divorce and by the way plenty of people
in the media never went to her and asked
her specifically what she meant we did
detailing a plan to decentralize the
federal government and of course the
media mob wasted no time attacking her
with false accusations that she was
talking about secession now
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
joins us with more congresswoman welcome
back
um I want to settle the issue of the
national divorce but first what happened
to you
um I've had my own incidents in the
course of my career it's not fun when it
happened when it happens what happened
well last night I was having dinner with
two members of my staff and we were
working preparing for committee hearings
today and then we were approached some a
woman came over to my table came and
stood very close to me and started
verbally attacking me calling me all
kinds of names and then another member
of her party started screaming Fu
Marjorie as loud as he possibly could
over and over and over again inside this
restaurant they have no respect for the
restaurant the staff and the other
people dining there here's what it is
Sean you know back when Hillary Clinton
declared that we're all deplorables they
basically tried to claim that we're
second-class citizens simply because
we're conservative and then Maxine
Waters with her wherever you see them
you make a crowd and you surround them
and you attack them this was the dog
whistle for all of the people on the
left Democrat voters everywhere and
fully supported by the Democrat Party to
attack Republicans in public no matter
what there is no line they will not
cross and it is disrespectful they are
insane they are crazy and it needs to
stop right now it happened to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders it happened to Senator
Cruz it happened to a lot of prominent
conservatives in the country I'm glad
you're okay congresswoman and you know
honestly we may be getting to the point
where every elected official especially
in Congress is going to need their own
personal security guard because I think
we have to protect every institution and
every elected official regardless of
what their politics are so we we had you
on to talk about absolutely
I I had you on both radio and TV on the
issue of this National divorce I wanna
and it was obvious after I interviewed
you that people do not understand what
you're saying so I want to get into more
detail which we got into in radio
because we had more time and you are not
calling for secession in any way shape
manner or form and and I just even said
that night I said I think the majority
of Americans want us to be the United
States of America
let's talk specifically about what you
mean you're not talking about separate
countries or secession is that correct
that's right Sean and first of all I
want to thank you very much you are one
of the only ones that actually was
willing to ask me what I'm talking about
everyone else just talked about me and
assumed what I was saying and accused me
of of trying to start civil war accusing
me of secession and all kinds of things
what I'm talking about is reducing the
size of our federal government and
giving more power and control to our
states to be the identity that they want
to be whether it's blue or red because
the division in our country has gotten
to a dangerous point to the point where
I experience it on a daily basis being
attacked in public is no fun but we also
have to remember it's not just elected
members of Congress or or famous you
know Republican spokesman or political
commentators like you and others but
it's also regular people maybe people
that wear a Maga hat that have been
attacked for years now and we are fed up
we're fed up with Democrat poll policies
we're fed up with the woke ideology
being shoved down our throat and we're
tired of our children being brainwashed
into these same ideas we want our own
safe space and we deserve it and the
federal government is so out of control
the debt is insane we need to take power
away from the federal government and
Reign that entity back in and and truly
let the states have the power they
deserve you're talking about reducing
the size power of the federal government
giving more power to the states in other
words Federalism is a good thing uh what
would you say about cases like we see
counties in Oregon wanting to join Idaho
we see uh Buckhead I used to live in in
Georgia for four years where you are
um and Buckhead wants to separate for
example from Atlanta have their own
Police Department their own government
so you have these these examples where
people want to join up with another
state or another County or another Town
should they have the right to do that
absolutely don't we believe in Freedom
in America isn't that what America is
all about is it's it's the it's the
people and their choices and the freedom
to do so I'm a huge supporter of
Buckhead City you know Buckhead is a
victim of the crime in Atlanta just like
the crime in Chicago and let me tell you
something about Atlanta Atlanta has a
higher murder rate now than Chicago and
look at what's happening to Mayor Lori
Lightfoot she is being kicked out of
being the mayor of Chicago and hopefully
they finish the job because she doesn't
deserve that position she ruined that
City with crime and Buckhead is fed up
with it I'm hoping she gets her ass
kicked tonight and loses I really am
um sorry I'm just being honest me too
let me ask you this I think this is
really important
I don't see middle ground for example if
you want to defund and dismantle the
police and you want no bail how do you
reconcile that with the rest of us that
believe in Law and Order and safety in
security as a prerequisite to pursue
happiness
um how do you reconcile those that want
open borders and those that want the
laws enforced and and secure borders how
do you reconcile energy Independence and
those that are willing to like Joe Biden
you know import three million barrels of
oil from Venezuela and make Venezuela
Rich again when we can be creating
high-paying career jobs in America and
being good for our national uh security
how do you reconcile these major
differences
well just as you just stated you know
what you can't reconcile those major
differences because they do not come
together and that's how far apart we are
today with the Republican party and the
Democrat Party but you know what
Republican voters are sick and tired of
it conservative Americans are fed up
with it there are so many Americans
today that whether they vote or not they
are sick and tired of the political
divide and the political pendulum that
is swinging back and forth and back and
forth and destroying this country it's
time for us to have our own ideas and be
protected in our own States and that's
why I'm calling for a reduction in the
federal government the power the size
and the spending power that has made the
American people fed up and discuss it uh
congresswoman number one we're glad
you're safe number two we're glad you
had a chance to clarify all of this uh
although I thought it was pretty
straightforward when we discussed it the
last time thank you for being with us
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight